the reminders that covert is ever
present
are inescapable in leicester one of the
areas where the so-called indian variant
is now the dominant strain to prevent
infection
the injection thousands more are getting
their covert jabs
but for those on the front line of this
crisis it may not be a voluntary
decision
for much longer the government could
make it compulsory
it would be incumbent on any responsible
government to have the debate to have
the
to do the thinking as to how we go about
protecting the most vulnerable
by making make sure that those who look
after them are vaccinated
it may become a condition of employment
83 percent of front-line healthcare
workers
in england have had their first dose but
the government says
to reduce the risk of transmission on
hospital wards that figure
needs to be much higher with over 57
000 members of staff not having had
their vaccine yet it's thought
hesitancy over the jab may have a part
to play
dr julian tang has both had covid19 and
been involved in the fight against it
he says cultural nervousness is still an
issue
forcing people isn't the answer i think
that
healthcare workers should be vaccinated
to protect them from the virus from the
infection that they could then pass to
their patients
but again compulsory is a difficult word
you can't force people to be vaccinated
the best you can do is what i've been
doing is trying to persuade them
with factual arguments but why it's
safer to get vaccinated
it's as the nhs is struggling in some
areas to manage the
unprecedented backlog of patients caused
by the pandemic
in the west country the ambulance
service declared a critical incident
but are prioritizing the most severe
cases it's a similar picture
across the nation we've got people who
we think have held off from coming in
but it's now got to a point there
their illness or their condition that
they really do have to have treatment
but when they turn up to
a e we're having to admit larger numbers
of people than we normally would at this
time of year
and they're needing complex and longer
treatment a consultation on the
mandatory immunizing of care home
workers closed only a few days ago
the same process may start for hospital
staff soon
they've spent the past 16 months
protecting us now they might not get a
choice
on whether to protect themselves harinag
sky news
in leicester